aber sowas von derartig spannend und was
geht es denn heute ja du Günter koitwert
mal sehen sich ein bisschen noch so
Zweisamkeit also vor allem wenn man
jetzt Single ist weil klar die
Heizkosten die Energiekosten
gegeneinander auf die Zeit muss sie dann
lieber mit einem Partner jetzt gehen wir
vorher auf die Suche und wenn man sie so
kennenlernen für erstes Date geht mir
normalerweise mit Namen zum Essen aber
das ist gar nicht so ohne da kann man so
viel falsch machen weil er nur was man
dort steht
die Schweinshaxen bestellst du ein
bisschen fressen und dann denkst du ja
gut vielleicht nehme lieber an Salat
aber dann kommt das so Schüssel daher
und dann hantierst du da so ewig rum ich
weiß gar nicht wie man sie da überhaupt
einfach Gespräch konzentrieren soll sehr
schwierig in einem Lokal also so zum
Essen bei mir so benimmbuchsen die Macht
immer und und rot und in dem Buch ist
gestanden im Restaurant auf keinen Fall
den Salat einschneiden darf man nicht
machen ist ein absolutes No-Go bei mir
Chinesen sagen und
ich war noch wirklich war mit dem
Restaurant und die haben Salatblätter
gehabt die waren so groß wie
Badehandtücher und und ich habe es dann
natürlich nicht klar geschnitten ich
habe da noch ausgeschaut wir wenigsten
Salatsoße ins Restaurant
sämtliche Bestandteile so durch
sämtliche Finger so durch Baden
sie wird hellhörig wenn sie dir
irgendwie Selleriesalat bestellt oder
Austern oder Rotwein weil das ist ja
alles Potenz fördernd und
ich ging immer ja gut wenn der das nötig
hat dann versprich immer von der
späteren Performance jetzt an ihn zu Fuß
aber
wenn jetzt der zum Beispiel ganz klar so
Austern und ein Liter Rotwein da können
sie ja sehen aus dem vorher zwei
[Gelächter]
die Namen von dieser Hand also wenn man
so 18 ist trifft man sehr gerne in der
Cocktailbar und wenn der Typ dann einen
Sex on the Beach steht dann du hast
gesehen
überhaupt nicht aus also bei ich war nie
im Cocktailbars überhaupt
und
außerdem
und äh und jetzt habe ich mitgekriegt
das sind so Cocktailbars dass du Getränk
gibt es Orgasmus Horst
und die Stellen schon lustig vor was
wenn du ein paar drin habt und dann sagt
der E-Book über bringt man Orgasmus ihre
bringst dauern aber meins erst mal bis
jetzt
[Gelächter]
aber
in der bayerischen Küche gibt es ganz
früh so schlüpfige Sachen es ist mir
erst wieder aufgefallen ich war auf so
einem Date mit so einem Instagram und du
also es war mal fast ein bisschen direkt
draufgelegt was der hat mir schon so
dann stellt sie dir doch glatt ich
glaube um mit zum provozieren hat sie
dir bestellt Nackidei
also wo ist die FKK Variante von der
Weißwurst ja und es hat ihm eine kleine
Nachspeise
und ich meine es ist nur so
schmalzgebäcke aber mir war es trotzdem
ein bisschen früh aber zum Glück von ihm
werden also auch kulinarisch ich habe
mir dann einfach gerade mit Fleisch habe
ich mir bestellt saure Zipfel und ein
Tag
[Applaus]
[Musik]
du war schön dass du da warst hier
wieder viele erfahren und ich freue mich
aufs nächste Mal Claudia Pichler
[Applaus]
[Musik]